[ Speaking French ]
[ Applause ]
WE ARE, I AM DELIGHTED TO BE
CONDUCTING A DRAFT ONCE AGAIN.
WELCOME.
IT IS A RETURN TO NORMALCY.
WE ARE THRILLED THAT THE DRAFT
IS IN THE CITY THAT HAS PLAYED
HOST TO THE FIRST NHL DRAFT BACK
IN 1963 AND HAS.
HOME TO THE MOST NHL DRAFTS
SINCE.
[ BOOING ]
NOT SURE WHY YOU'RE DOING THAT.
IT'S YOUR CITY.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE.
WE HAD A TRAGEDY HERE IN
MONTREAL YESTERDAY WITH THE
PASSING OF BRIAN MARCHMENT WHO
WAS HERE WITH THE CAPACITY OF
THE SAN JOSE SHARKS.
OBVIOUSLY THE CONDOLENCES OF THE
ENTIRE NHL FAMILY GO OUT TO
BRIAN'S FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND I
WOULD ASK EVERYONE TO STAND FOR
A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
[ BOOING ]
YOU HAVE TO HOLD IT FOR A
SECOND.
WAIT A SECOND.
I'M HONOURED TO BE COMPANIED
TONIGHT BY TONIA BOSSI AND
MARTIN LaFLEUR.
THE NHL LOST TWO OF ITS
LEGENDARY PLAYERS AND MONTREAL
LOST TWO OF ITS MOST BELOVED
SONS AND TANYA AND MARTIN LOST
THEIR CHERISHED FATHERS, WE
STILL AND ALWAYS WILL FEEL THEIR
LOSSES DEEPLY, BUT TONIGHT WE
CELEBRATE THEIR LIVES.
[ Cheering ]
AND WE RECALL THE CAREERS BEGAN
ON A NIGHT JUST LIKE THIS IN NHL
DRAFTS HELD IN MONTREAL.
[ Cheering ]
[ Speaking French ]
IN 1971, THANKS TO SAM'S
WIZARDRY, THE MONTREAL CANADIENS
DRAFTED MY FATHER.
[ Cheering ]
[ Speaking French ]
>> THE LaFLEUR FAMILY WOULD LIKE
TO WISH THE BEST OF LUCK TO ALL
THE PLAYERS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE 2022 NHL DRAFT.
ENJOY THIS MOMENT.
IT'S ONCE IN A LIFETIME.
THANK YOU.
CHEER CHEER
[ Speaking French ]
[ Cheering ]
MY FATHER'S DREAM WAS TO PLAY IN
THE NHL.
>> BOSSY!
BOSSY!
>> MY FATHER'S DREAM WAS TO PLAY
IN THE NHL.
45 YEARS AGO HE WAS DRAFTED BY
THE NEW YORK ISLANDERS AND HE
TOLD THE G.M. THAT HE WOULD
SCORE 50 GOALS DURING HIS FIRST
SEASON.
WELL UP ENTIRED BY GUY LaFLEUR
AND WEARING THIS JERSEY, HE
SCORED 53.
[ Applause ]
DESPITE HIS SHORTENED LIFE AND
CAREER, MY DAD'S DREAM CAME TRUE
AND IF HE WAS HERE TONIGHT HE
WOULD TELL YOU TO DREAM BIG, AS
BIG AS YOU CAN.
[ Speaking French ]
THANK YOU.
[ Applause ]